and it looks like we have some earnings
out from Tesla Motors scarlet is looking
through those right now it isn't a loss
as expected for the second quarter
adjusted loss of a dollar six per share
much wider than what analysts had been
looking for they anticipated a loss of
60 cents a share and certainly bigger
than what we had last year or in the
first quarter as well in terms of second
quarter deliveries this came out to be
fourteen thousand four hundred and two
which looks to be a little bit higher
than what Tesla had pre announced which
was fourteen thousand three hundred
seventy what we also want to know of
course from Tesla is what kind of
outlook it has when it comes to the
deliveries in the second half as we go
through that the second quarter adjusted
gross margin was twenty point eight
percent and Matt I know that's a big
point of contention here as Tesla as
targeted a specific number and people
are wondering especially with the lower
cost model coming out whether it can
actually achieve that right the model
three is the real point of contention
because look we just talked to Charlie
Anderson and he was saying he's excited
about the fact they got 350,000
pre-orders and a thousand bucks a pop
for a car that nobody's ever seen before
or at least no one's ever seen a
production version that's really
impressive the question is can they ramp
up production quickly enough to hit that
goal a lot of people will probably guess
that they won't be able to do it on time
since they haven't really ever hit any
goals on time but the point is that they
do eventually hit them I'm just
scrolling through the the statement
right now and looking to see what Tesla
expects as far as production and demand
they say that they're on track to
support deliveries of 50,000 new Model S
and Model X vehicles during the second
half so that's something that a lot of
people are wondering they say vehicle
production efficiency is improving
rapidly and they're increasing their
weekly production rate even further
barring any supply constraints they plan
to exit q3 with a steady production rate
of 2,200 vehicles a week and plan to
increase production to 2,400 vehicles a
week in q4 so there's a little bit of an
outlook there from Tesla as far as their
production